Shure: 听过吗啊
Shure: Have you heard it?
Tasha:听过
Tasha: Yeah, I've heard it.
Alice:真没听过
Alice: I really haven't heard it.
Shure: 听过吗
Shure: Have you heard it?
Tasha:谁没听过
Tasha: Who hasn't heard it?
Lucia:没听过
Lucia: I haven't heard it.
Shure: 完了
Shure: Oh no.
Lucia:真没听过哈哈
Lucia: I really haven't heard it, haha.
Alice:好像听过又好像没听过呢
Alice: It feels like I have heard it, but also like I haven't.
Shure: 朴树的
Shure: It's by Pu Shu.
Shure: 这首就比较欢快
Shure: This one is quite cheerful.
Shure: 这是备选一
Shure: This is option one.
Jake:对备选可以
Jake: Yeah, option one works.
Shure: 然后
Shure: Then...
Katrina: 备选二是什么
Katrina: What's option two?
Shure: 备选二是
Shure: Option two is...
Katrina: 开心超人
Katrina: Happy Superman.
Shure: 开心超人
Shure: Happy Superman.
Shure: 大家小时候看过吗
Shure: Did everyone watch it when they were kids?
Shure: 完了你这
Shure: Oh no, this...
Shure: 明显跟我们有点代沟啊哈哈
Shure: Clearly, there's a generation gap here, haha.
Alice:开心往前飞
Alice: Happy flying forward.
Shure: 对对对
Shure: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina: 就是这首歌
Katrina: It's this song
Shure: 然后被
Shure: And then...
Jake:还有这是个动画片吗
Jake: Is this a cartoon?
Shure: 对动画片
Shure: Yeah, it's a cartoon.
Jake:这这这长什么样啊
Jake: What does it look like?
Jake:里边的角色
Jake: The characters inside.
Shure: 就是那个红色的
Shure: It's the red one.
Shure: 那个叫开心超人
Shure: It's called Happy Superman.
Jake:你认识这些这些玩意吗
Jake: Do you know these things?
Lucia:哦我见过
Lucia: Oh, I've seen it.
Jake:完了还是有带差
Jake: But still, it's a bit different.
Lucia:但我没但我没看过
Lucia: But I haven't watched it.
Lucia:应该我见都没见过我见过
Lucia: Maybe I haven't seen it, but I've seen it.
Jake:你知道这玩意吗
Jake: Do you know this thing?
Jake:你也不知道
Jake: You don't know either.
Nicous: 跟他一个水平
Nicous: Same level as him.
Jake:哦水平还是比我高的
Jake: Oh, his level is higher than mine.
Shure: 那还有下一首是这个
Shure: Then the next one is this.
Katrina: 你跳舞吗
Katrina: Do you dance?
Katrina: 不会吧
Katrina: Probably not.
Shure: 这个
Shure: This one.
Shure: 别猜哈
Shure: Don't guess.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 有点疑惑了
Katrina: A bit confused now.
Katrina: 哈哈哈好
Katrina: Haha, alright.
Shure: 好 那就
Shure: Okay, then...
Jake:我这个虽然没听过但是很好唱的感觉
Jake: I haven't heard this, but it feels easy to sing.
Shure: 对很好唱
Shure: Yeah, it's easy to sing.
Katrina: 三选一当开头
Katrina: Choose one out of three to start.
Katrina: 三选一
Katrina: One out of three.
Shure: 咱们听过最多的就是那个
Shure: The one we've heard the most is that one.
Lucia: 难忘今宵
Lucia: Unforgettable Tonight.
Katrina: 难忘今宵在最后的我们
Katrina: Unforgettable Tonight at our end.
Jake:开场难忘今宵
Jake: Start with Unforgettable Tonight.
Katrina: 开开开场要选
Katrina: Choose, choose, choose for the start.
Jake:结束
Jake: Finish.
Jake:欢迎大家
Jake: Welcome everyone.
Lucia: 我投票给雨轩了
Lucia: I vote for Yuxuan.
Lucia:难忘今宵
Lucia: Unforgettable Tonight.
Lucia:好我一票已经送出去了
Lucia: Okay, my vote is in.
Nicous: 我也投票难忘今宵
Nicous: I also vote for "Unforgettable Tonight."
Jake:我觉得挺好
Jake: I think it's pretty good.
Jake:难忘今宵
Jake: "Unforgettable Tonight."
Nicous: 我真是觉得挺好
Nicous: I really think it's good.
Jake:对对好我是
Jake: Yeah, yeah, good, I am...
Jake:我说开场我说开场我说开场开场对
Jake: I mean for the opening, I mean for the opening, I mean for the opening, right.
Katrina: 但是我们要开头这是开场的
Katrina: But we need an opening, this is for the opening.
Jake:难忘今宵
Jake: "Unforgettable Tonight."
Tasha:难忘今宵是
Tasha: "Unforgettable Tonight" is...
Katrina: 难忘今宵能用吉他弹吗
Katrina: Can "Unforgettable Tonight" be played with a guitar?
Lucia:哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:摇滚难忘今宵
Jake: Rock version of "Unforgettable Tonight."
Jake:可以吗啊要
Jake: Is that okay?
Katrina: 那你好交给你了
Katrina: Then it's up to you.
Lucia:租个琴吧
Lucia: Let's rent a guitar.
Jake:他带过来的
Jake: He brought it over.
Katrina: 他有
Katrina: He has it.
Lucia: 哦那可以
Lucia: Oh, then it's fine.
Nicous: 正好放在宿舍没啥用
Nicous: It's just sitting in the dorm, not being used.
Shure: 那你怎么再搬回去呢
Shure: How are you going to move it back?
Nicous: 我直接他妈搁到二手卖了
Nicous: I'll just sell it second-hand.
Shure: 能卖出去吗
Shure: Can you sell it?
Lucia:你是电钢琴还是电键盘了啊
Lucia: Is it an electric piano or an electric keyboard?
Nicous: 电钢
Nicous: Electric piano.
Lucia:哎那我也可以试试
Lucia: Oh, then I can give it a try too.
Nicous: 大一买的 大一弹了很多后来就不弹了
Nicous: I bought it in my first year, played a lot then, but not anymore.
Jake:就三个选项吗
Jake: Only three options?
Katrina: 开场的就三选一
Katrina: For the opening, just three options.
Katrina: 三选一都已经选不出来了
Katrina: Can't even choose from the three.
Lucia:你说竟然没有琴房
Lucia: Can't believe there's no music room.
Nicous: 我们是整个学校就只有一个练钢琴
Nicous: Our whole school only has one piano practice room.
Jake:在哪啊
Jake: Where is it?
Nicous: 在沙河
Nicous: In Shahe.
Shure: 没有不是
Shure: No, it's not.
Lucia:在沙河
Lucia: In Shahe.
Katrina: 什么东西啊
Katrina: What is it?
Katrina: 公用什么
Katrina: A public what?
Katrina: 就一个公用钢琴
Katrina: Just one public piano.
Alice:沙河那个校区吗
Alice: In the Shahe campus?
Lucia:还在沙河
Lucia: Still in Shahe.
Nicous: 对啊 本部的那种就是
Nicous: Yeah, the one from the main office is just like...
Shure: 哎我他妈手机去哪去了
Shure: Damn, where did my phone go?
Lucia:我还以为我们学校琴房要付钱
Lucia: I thought we had to pay for the piano room at our school.
Lucia:已经很不可思议了呢
Lucia: That's already quite surprising.
Shure: 那就
Shure: So...
Shure: new boy吧大家感觉听的是听过得最多的
Shure: How about "New Boy"? Everyone seems to have heard it the most.
Shure: 就来这首new boy好不好
Shure: Let's go with this song, "New Boy", okay?
Katrina: 行牛new boy
Katrina: Sure, "New Boy" it is.
Jake:因为没有对
Jake: Because there's no...
Lucia:我以为你说在哪不用付钱
Lucia: I thought you meant a place where we don't have to pay.
Shure: 好 记住了吗
Shure: Alright, got it memorized?
Tasha:new boy是怎么唱
Tasha: How do you sing "New Boy"?
Shure: new boy
Shure: "New Boy"...
Tasha:哪一首
Tasha: Which one?
Shure: 就是这时的我看见到处是阳光是吧
Shure: It's the one that goes "At this moment, I see sunlight everywhere," right?
Alice:啊这个听过
Alice: Ah, I've heard this one.
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Katrina: 行那就这个
Katrina: Sure, let's go with this one.
Shure: 那就这个了
Shure: Alright, this is it.
Shure: 大家回去多加练习
Shure: Everyone, practice more when you get back.
Alice:是什么这个要开场
Alice: What, this is going to be the opening?
Tasha:开场对
Tasha: Yeah, the opening.
Shure: 对开场
Shure: Yep, the opening.
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: No worries.
Katrina: 但是我们几个人一起唱
Katrina: But we're all singing together.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 跑调没关系
Katrina: It's okay if we're off-key.
Alice:好 好
Alice: Alright, alright.
Katrina: 也没什么人看
Katrina: Not many people will be watching anyway.
Shure: 说唱也行你就突然来呦
Shure: You can even rap, just suddenly go "yo".
Shure: 就这样也可以
Shure: Just like that, it's fine too.
Lucia:好你说lou那一段这是艰巨任务
Lucia: Okay, you know that part where you say "lou", that's a tough task.
Lucia:交给你了
Lucia: It's up to you.
Katrina: 然后中
Katrina: Then in the middle...
Katrina: 我们本来定的是两首
Katrina: We originally planned for two songs.
Katrina: 一手开场欢快一点
Katrina: One for the opening to be lively.
Katrina: 一手中间那种配合晚上那种悠闲
Katrina: And one for the middle to suit the evening's relaxed vibe.
Katrina: emo一点的那个
Katrina: Something a bit emo.
Katrina: 选的是perfect和唯一二选一
Katrina: We chose between "Perfect" and "The Only One".
Katrina: 哎黄老板
Katrina: Hey, Nicous.
Shure: 你这个一定听过了吧
Shure: You've definitely heard this one before, right?
Shure: 混欧美圈的啊
Shure: It's popular in the Western circles.
Lucia:啊哪个
Lucia: Oh, which one?
Katrina: 黄老板的perfect
Katrina: Ed Sheeran's "Perfect".
Shure: 黄老板的perfect啊
Shure: Ed Sheeran's "Perfect", right?
Lucia:听过但我这个听的不多
Lucia: I've heard it, but not that often.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Oh, okay.
Lucia:黄老板听的最多的应该shape of you
Lucia: The Ed Sheeran song I listen to the most is "Shape of You".
Katrina: 好像唯一不适合合唱
Katrina: Seems like the only one not suitable for a duet.
Nicous: 适合你唱
Nicous: It's perfect for you to sing.
Shure: 行
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 那我们要不
Shure: So, how about...
Shure: 你给大家solo一个女团舞吧
Shure: You do a solo girl group dance for everyone?
Tasha:哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Katrina: 我要跳也要拉着你
Katrina: If I'm dancing, you're coming with me.
Jake:你要啊
Jake: You want to?
Tasha:你要不来一段吧
Tasha: How about you give it a try?
Tasha:哈哈哈你好合适啊
Tasha: Haha, you'd be perfect for it.
Shure: 我不行的
Shure: I can't do it.
Shure: 我害羞
Shure: I'm too shy.
Shure: 行
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 那就订perfect
Katrina: Then let's settle on "Perfect".
Jake:你跳一个
Jake: You dance to it.
Shure: perfect
Shure: "Perfect".
Jake:然后以后就是
Jake: And then in the future...
Katrina: 中间一一下
Katrina: Do a little bit in the middle.
Alice:中间的不用合唱吧
Alice: We don't need to do a duet in the middle, right?
Jake:以后这种计算机视觉的会议啊
Jake: In the future, at these computer vision conferences...
Katrina: 可以合唱啊
Katrina: We could do a duet.
Jake:就会邀请你
Jake: They will invite you.
Alice:可以合
Alice: We could.
Katrina: 要不然就我俩
Katrina: Or just the two of us.
Shure: 我就可以当学术蝗虫了是吧
Shure: So I can just be an academic freeloader, right?
Jake:不是就是会邀请你就去演出
Jake: No, they will invite you to perform.
Jake:当就是你知道那个妮娜
Jake: Like, you know, that Nina.
Shure: 妮娜是
Shure: Who's Nina?
Jake:就是信号处里的那个那个女的
Jake: The woman from the signal processing department.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Jake:然后这种顶级会议都会邀请他去
Jake: And those top conferences always invite her.
Jake:然后这个
Jake: And then this...
Shure: 那这样
Shure: Like this...
Shure: 以后就顶级会议都会邀请我去是吗
Shure: So from now on, they'll invite me to all the top meetings, right?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 真的没有
Shure: Really, no.
Shure: 每每次会给报差旅并且
Shure: Every time they'll cover travel expenses and...
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Shure: 部分劳务
Shure: Some labor costs.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake:然后这个说是说土灵奖得主请你上台
Jake: And then it was said that the Earth Spirit Award winner invites you to the stage.
Shure: 哇哇
Shure: Wow, wow.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 所以我手机去哪了
Shure: So where did my phone go?
Jake:所以你要不要跳
Jake: So, do you want to jump?
Alice:要的要的
Alice: Yes, yes.
Shure: 我不要我不要
Shure: I don't want to, I don't want to.
Shure: 哈哈哈你不要给我画这些饼
Shure: Hahaha, don't paint these pictures for me.
Lucia:跳跳跳你跳
Lucia: Jump, jump, you jump.
Lucia:我站你第二排
Lucia: I'll stand in the second row.
Lucia:就是你在我前面
Lucia: Right in front of me.
Lucia:我站你第二排给你伴舞
Lucia: I'll be in the second row dancing for you.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia:实际上那天徐璐正开始跳
Lucia: Actually, that day Xu Lu started dancing.
Katrina: 是我偷偷的从排后面下去了
Katrina: I secretly snuck out from the back row.
Katrina: 是吧哈哈
Katrina: Right, haha.
Alice:我们一共准备三首歌吗
Alice: Are we preparing three songs in total?
Shure: 两两首难忘今宵是
Shure: Two, two songs. "Unforgettable Tonight" is one.
Katrina: 唱吗
Katrina: Sing?
Shure: 拿音响放吧
Shure: Just play it on the speakers.
Katrina: 拿音响放
Katrina: Play it on the speakers.
Katrina: 然后我们就合一合
Katrina: And then we'll just join in.
Katrina: 难忘今宵你先一边收拾碟子一边
Katrina: "Unforgettable Tonight", you clean the dishes while...
Shure: 哦f和弦
Shure: Oh, an F chord.
Shure: 行那就这么定了
Shure: Okay, that's settled then.
Shure: 第二首的话
Shure: As for the second song...
Shure: 哎
Shure: Uh...
Jake:这个
Jake: This one...
Shure: 不是这个不是
Shure: No, not this one.
Shure: 这个perfect大家没听过吧
Shure: This "Perfect", everyone hasn't heard it, right?
Jake:听过
Jake: Heard it.
Alice:没有
Alice: No.
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh...
Jake:唱个太多的新歌
Jake: Singing too many new songs.
Jake:新歌新歌
Jake: New songs, new songs.
Jake:不行老歌吧
Jake: No, let's do an old song.
Shure: 这个大家听过吧
Shure: Everyone's heard this, right?
Alice:没有
Alice: No.
Shure: 大家都听过什么比较舒缓一点的歌
Shure: What soothing songs has everyone heard?
Lucia:第二首竟然要舒缓一点的
Lucia: The second one should be a bit soothing.
Shure: 对一人报一首
Shure: Yeah, everyone pick one.
Alice:想不起来
Alice: Can't think of any.
Shure: 舒缓的
Shure: Soothing ones.
Shure: 我教大家唱我们乐队的原创歌曲吧
Shure: I'll teach everyone one of our band's original songs.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Nicous: 听完修硕的摇滚我就发烧了
Nicous: After listening to Shure's rock, I got a fever.
Katrina: 哎那耳熟能详一点的那种
Katrina: How about something more familiar?
Jake:草与虫之歌
Jake: Grass and Insect Song.
Katrina: 那种周杰伦的那种弹唱呗
Katrina: How about we play and sing a Jay Chou song?
Lucia:搞笑
Lucia: Funny.
Lucia:周杰伦的舒缓一些
Lucia: A more soothing Jay Chou song.
Katrina: 安静然后再叫安静
Katrina: Quiet, then let's sing "Quiet."
Shure: 晴天
Shure: Sunny Day.
Jake:一谋哥
Jake: One brother.
Shure: 晴天大家听过吗
Shure: Has everyone heard "Sunny Day?"
Katrina: 谁没听过呀
Katrina: Who hasn't?
Shure: 那不行就这个吧
Shure: Alright, let's do this one.
Shure: 我搜一下晴天
Shure: I'll search for "Sunny Day."
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 在晚上唱晴天
Katrina: Singing "Sunny Day" at night.
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Alice:那就唱夜曲吧
Alice: Then let's sing "Nocturne."
Tasha:晚上唱夜曲
Tasha: Singing "Nocturne" at night.
Jake:晚上唱夜曲
Jake: Singing "Nocturne" at night.
Alice:晚上唱夜曲
Alice: Singing "Nocturne" at night.
Katrina: 睛天
Katrina: "Sunny Day."
Shure: 好像卡住了
Shure: Seems stuck.
Shure: 啊我知道来吧
Shure: Ah, I know, let's go.
Shure: OK就是这个样子
Shure: OK, just like this.
Katrina: 你哼一下
Katrina: Hum a bit.
Katrina: 行那就这首
Katrina: Alright, let's go with this one.
Jake:好好
Jake: Okay, okay
Shure: 太棒了
Shure: Awesome
Nicous: 所以现在
Nicous: So now
Katrina: 定了
Katrina: It's settled
Shure: 我们定完了
Shure: We've finalized it
Jake:行
Jake: Alright
Katrina: 到时候收尾就是你钢琴独奏一下
Katrina: And then you'll end with a piano solo
Tasha:英文歌
Tasha: English song
Nicous: 全是中文歌
Nicous: All Chinese songs
Shure: 新加坡新加坡国语普及率很高
Shure: In Singapore, Mandarin is widely spoken
Lucia:可以可以我支持
Lucia: Sure, sure, I support it
Lucia:可以可以
Lucia: Sure, sure
Katrina: 再自由组合呗
Katrina: Let's mix it up
Katrina: 想想
Katrina: Think about it
Katrina: 就是这个
Katrina: That's it
Katrina: 就是放在晚上的那个环节
Katrina: That's the evening segment
Katrina: 也可以邀请别人他们一起
Katrina: We can also invite others to join us
Alice:哎嘉宾到晚上几点结束啊
Alice: Hey, what time do the guests leave in the evening?
Katrina: 8点
Katrina: 8 PM
Alice:他们吃饭吗
Alice: Do they eat?
Alice:需要吃的吧
Alice: They need food, right?
Katrina: 就是不是说点披萨吗
Katrina: Didn't we say we'll order pizza?
Alice:傍晚达美乐
Alice: Domino's in the evening
Jake:对对对超级大披萨
Jake: Yes, yes, a super big pizza
Shure: 秋吧蘸点披萨
Shure: Autumn with pizza dip
Shure: 有那个超级大披
Shure: There's that super big pizza
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Shure: 你练习吧
Shure: You practice
Shure: 我觉得你们的讨论
Shure: I think your discussion
Jake:可以
Jake: Alright
Shure: 已经有有了一个结果
Shure: Already has a conclusion
Shure: 嗯那我们
Shure: Yeah, so we
Jake:那我们最后干嘛呢
Jake: So what do we do at the end?
Jake:最后一天干嘛来着
Jake: What are we doing on the last day?
Jake:先唱这三首歌
Jake: Sing these three songs first
Jake:然后呢
Jake: And then?
Shure: 先唱两首
Shure: Sing two songs first
Shure: 然后最后放难忘今宵
Shure: Then play "Unforgettable Tonight" at the end
Shure: 就是散场的时候放难忘今宵
Shure: Play "Unforgettable Tonight" when the event ends
Jake:好然后先唱两首歌啊
Jake: Okay, so sing two songs first
Katrina: 其实如果有自己想唱的就到时候
Katrina: Actually, if you have a song you want to sing, then at that time...
Katrina: 反正连伴奏嘛
Katrina: Anyway, there's accompaniment.
Katrina: 连全民k歌伴奏
Katrina: With the karaoke accompaniment.
Katrina: 然后自己自己练就行
Katrina: Then you can just practice it yourself.
Jake:嗯先唱两首歌
Jake: Hmm, let's sing two songs first.
Jake:然后室友问答是吗
Jake: Then a Q&A with roommates, right?
Alice:卡拉自助是呗
Alice: It's like self-service karaoke, right?
Katrina: 卡拉自助晚上没有问答
Katrina: Self-service karaoke doesn't have Q&A at night.
Katrina: 问答是下午那天定的
Katrina: The Q&A is scheduled for the afternoon that day.
Shure: 蠢 太蠢了 我也琴铺来
Shure: Stupid, so stupid. I'll come and play too.
Katrina: 对明天准备一下
Katrina: Right, let's prepare for tomorrow.
Shure: 对明天准备一下
Shure: Yeah, let's prepare for tomorrow.
Katrina: QQ给我们出一个
Katrina: Let's get QQ to give us one.
Lucia:写一下到楼上写一下
Lucia: Write it down, go upstairs and write it down.
Shure: 然后大家记得通知自己的嘉宾
Shure: And everyone remember to notify your guests.
Shure: 就是带一点闲置的二手物品
Shure: To bring some idle second-hand items.
Shure: 来进行拍卖
Shure: For the auction.
Shure: 交换好吧
Shure: For exchange, okay?
Katrina: 这个闲置二手物品是交换给谁
Katrina: Who are these idle second-hand items for?
Katrina: 交换给我们
Katrina: For us?
Katrina: 还是他们
Katrina: Or for them?
Shure: 就是拍卖吧
Shure: It's for auction.
Shure: 就是谁谁都可以来买
Shure: Anyone can come and buy.
Shure: 就是比如说好的
Shure: For example, okay.
Shure: 我现在拍卖这个
Shure: I'm auctioning this.
Shure: 这个这个
Shure: This, this.
Shure: 我珍藏多年的酱香型白酒
Shure: My treasured sauce-flavored baijiu.
Shure: 嗯自
Shure: Since...
Shure: 打我爷爷那年
Shure: From my grandfather's era.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 对我这是做了一个违背祖宗的决定
Shure: Yeah, I'm making a decision that goes against my ancestors.
Shure: 今天把这瓶酒拍卖给大家了
Shure: Today, I'm auctioning off this bottle of liquor to everyone.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: 然后我觉得这瓶酒的起拍价是
Shure: So I think the starting bid for this bottle is...
Alice:两块
Alice: Two bucks.
Shure: 两个EGO EGO币
Shure: 好吧我们就叫EGO币
Shure: Okay, let's call it 'Yigou' coins.
Jake:好EGO币可以一个coin
Jake: Okay, one 'Yigou' coin can be a coin.
Tasha:一个coinEGO
Jake:很虚拟啊这个
Jake: This is very virtual.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure: 我们把每个那个小币都上链吧
Shure: Let's put each of those small tokens on the chain.
Shure: 给他哈哈哈
Shure: Give it to him, hahaha.
Shure: 都想说哈哈
Shure: Everyone wants to say, haha.
Lucia:多少数啊
Lucia:可以把它注一下
Lucia: Can you mark it?
Shure: EGO币
Shure: One token.
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha
Nicous: 每当我们这个导入数据
Nicous: Whenever we import the data
Nicous: 导成功一期我们一勾币就产生
Nicous: Once it's successfully imported, a token is generated.
Jake:对对对好
Jake: Yes, yes, good.
Shure: ok
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 可以那就这么定了
Shure: Alright, let's settle on that.
Shure: 好
Shure: Good.
Shure: 然后明天商量一下具体的细则
Shure: Then let's discuss the specifics tomorrow.
Shure: 就是
Shure: Just...
Shure: 复现一下
Shure: Revisit it.
Shure: 我们
Shure: We...
Jake:再捋一遍那个时间线啊
Jake: Go over the timeline again.
Katrina: 三点啊 2点半到3点是
Katrina: At 3 o'clock, from 2:30 to 3...
Alice:嘉宾入场
Alice: Guests arrive.
Katrina: 嘉宾入场
Katrina: Guests arrive.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Yeah.
Jake:2点半到3点
Jake: From 2:30 to 3.
Jake:对嘉宾入场
Jake: Yes, guests arrive.
Jake:3点开始
Jake: Start at 3.
Jake:赚钱是吧
Jake: Making money, right?
Katrina: 对赚钱
Katrina: Yes, making money.
Katrina: 是自我介绍嘛
Katrina: Is it introductions?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 对自我介绍
Shure: Yes, introductions.
Jake:班饼开始自我介绍
Jake: Start introductions at 3.
Jake:三点开始自我介绍
Shure: 或者是讲故事
Shure: Or tell stories.
Jake:呃给多少钱呢
Jake: Uh, how much money?
Shure: 看我们心情给
Shure: Depends on our mood.
Shure: 对就是我们作为家
Shure: Yes, it's up to us.
Jake:就我们作为评委是吧
Jake: As the judges, right?
Jake:评委评委
Jake: Judges, judges
Jake:我们就坐着小板凳
Jake: We'll just sit on small stools
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah
Katrina: 那一上来就让他们自我介绍嘛
Katrina: Let's have them introduce themselves when they come up
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh
Shure: 我们先表演节目暖场
Shure: Let's perform a show to warm things up
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure
Katrina: 表演什么节目
Katrina: What kind of performance?
Shure: 我们给大家唱一个
Shure: We'll sing a song for everyone
Shure: 哈哈哈我给大家咬个打火机
Shure: Hahaha, I'll bite a lighter for everyone
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Alice:咬个什么打火机
Alice: Bite a what, a lighter?
Nicous: 他才艺很
Nicous: His talent is
Shure: 你不知道这个梗吗
Shure: You don't know this joke?
Shure: 没活就咬打火机吧
Shure: When there's nothing to do, bite a lighter
Nicous: 没活就咬打火机吧
Nicous: When there's nothing to do, bite a lighter
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahahaha
Shure: 你这就是
Shure: You're just
Shure: 哈哈哈好好好
Shure: Haha, alright, alright
Nicous: 牙咬不动
Nicous: Can't bite it with your teeth
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
Shure: 不知怎么整
Shure: No idea what to do
Katrina: 自我介绍前面还有一个环节
Katrina: There's another segment before the introductions
Katrina: 我看我拍的照片
Katrina: Let me check the photos I took
Jake:还有一个game
Jake: There's another game
Jake:game before party
Jake: Game before the party
Katrina: 先知识问答来着好像
Katrina: It's a trivia quiz, I think
Shure: game before party是啥来着
Shure: What's game before the party again?
Jake:拼那个拼图吗
Jake: Is it the puzzle?
Shure: 啊啊啊对对对
Shure: Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah
Alice:那个得拼
Alice: That one needs to be solved
Tasha:那个的拼好
Tasha: That one needs to be solved well
Lucia:不容易拼好
Lucia: It's not easy to solve
Jake:哈哈哈很难拼哦
Jake: Hahaha, it's really hard to solve
Lucia:别打伞或者别的game
Lucia: Or play umbrella or another game
Jake:或者别的game
Jake: Or another game
Jake:还有就是藏东西在你们各种各地方
Jake: And also hide things in various places for you
Lucia:复活节彩蛋
Lucia: Easter eggs
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Shure: 那有点
Shure: That's a bit...
Shure: 哦藏币是吧
Shure: Oh, it's Tibetan currency, right?
Jake:对藏币
Jake: Yes, Tibetan currency.
Shure: 然后这个拿拿到就归他们
Shure: Then once they get it, it's theirs.
Shure: 对对对一些散币对
Shure: Yes, yes, some scattered coins.
Shure: 1,000 来
Shure: 1,000, come on.
Shure: 哈哈哈我们我们撒一些币
Shure: Hahaha, we'll scatter some coins.
Shure: 简称撒币
Shure: Just call it "coin scattering."
Lucia:你先挖矿环节
Lucia: You first, the mining phase.
Jake:对对行
Jake: Yes, yes, okay.
Jake:那明天我们撒就撒
Jake: Then tomorrow, we'll scatter.
Jake:对明天我们当撒撒币
Jake: Yes, tomorrow we'll be coin scatterers.
Jake:嗯哈哈
Jake: Hmm, haha.
Jake:明天撒撒币
Jake: Tomorrow, coin scattering.
Shure: 明天撒撒币
Shure: Tomorrow, coin scattering.
Jake:撒撒币啊
Jake: Coin scattering, yeah.
Jake:我们50个币
Jake: We'll scatter 50 coins.
Jake:我们多少币
Jake: How many coins?
Lucia:我们多少币
Lucia: How many coins?
Lucia:150个
Lucia: 150.
Jake:150个币
Jake: 150 coins.
Shure: 150个
Shure: 150.
Jake:撒他
Jake: Scatter them.
Shure: 流 流通
Shure: Circulate, circulate.
Tasha: 50个我
Tasha: 50 for me.
Jake:不行
Jake: No.
Jake:哈哈哈有点太多了
Jake: Hahaha, that's a bit too much.
Shure: 流通有点太多
Shure: Circulating that much is too much.
Lucia:20
Lucia: 20.
Jake:撒他20个币
Jake: Scatter 20 coins.
Jake:哦对
Jake: Oh, right.
Lucia:光撒的只是一部分OK
Lucia: Only part of the scattered ones, okay?
Jake:对撒他20个币
Jake: Yes, scatter 20 coins.
Jake:然后
Jake: And then...
Lucia: 不能全撒
Lucia: We can't scatter all.
Jake:不能全撒
Jake: We can't scatter all.
Jake:对要保证金融市场事从无
Jake: Yes, we need to ensure the financial market is stable.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Katrina: 我是这边记得是两点半到3点入场
Katrina: I remember it's from 2:30 to 3:00 for entry.
Katrina: 然后introduction and Q&A是3点到3:40
Katrina: And the introduction and Q&A will be from 3:00 to 3:40.
Katrina: 嗯那这个暖场游戏是啥时候呢
Katrina: Hmm, so when is the warm-up game?
Katrina: 就在2点半到3点之间
Katrina: It's between 2:30 and 3:00.
Jake:对 2点半到三点
Jake: Yes, 2:30 to 3:00.
Tasha:暖场是什么游戏
Tasha: What game is the warm-up?
Jake:来的人就来
Jake: Whoever shows up can join.
Katrina: 找币
Katrina: Coin hunt.
Jake:对找币
Jake: Yes, coin hunt.
Jake:然后
Jake: And then...
Katrina: 找币
Katrina: Coin hunt.
Katrina: 然后想玩那个拼图的就玩拼图
Katrina: And if you want to play the puzzle game, you can play the puzzle.
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Jake:然后如果拼起来的话
Jake: And if you complete the puzzle...
Katrina: 可以奖励
Katrina: You get a reward.
Katrina: 拼不起来的
Katrina: If you can't complete it...
Lucia:拼不起来放心吧
Lucia: Don't worry, you won't complete it.
Alice:要不按照块拼吧
Alice: Maybe we should go piece by piece.
Jake:确实
Jake: True.
修确：就是你拼到几个
Shure: Like, how many pieces you put together...
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Shure: 那总共有几个块来着
Shure: So, how many pieces are there total?
Jake:大概几十个吧
Jake: About dozens.
Alice:好几十个吧
Alice: Quite a few, right?
Katrina: 他们有个就圆形的拼图很难拼
Katrina: They have a round puzzle that's really hard to complete.
Tasha:三十
Tasha: Thirty.
Jake:你们作为每拼起来的人
Jake: For those of you who can't complete it...
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Shure: 每
Shure: Each...
Jake:就就大概点评一下给个稍为
Jake: Just give a brief review and maybe...
Jake:随便给点钱吧要不就
Jake: Give some money or something...
Katrina: 反正他们那天拼了一个小时
Katrina: Anyway, they spent an hour on it that day.
Shure: 每拼进去多少个
Shure: For each piece you put in...
Shure: 然后我们给
Shure: We give...
Shure: 就比如说每拼进5个
Shure: For example, for every 5 pieces...
Shure: 我可以给你一个
Shure: I can give you one...
Shure: 你要能拼
Shure: If you can put together...
Tasha:拼5个就给一个币啊
Tasha: You give one coin for 5 pieces?
Tasha:你这小抠搜
Tasha: You're so stingy.
Tasha:抠搜的
Tasha: Stingy.
Alice:你知道那个有多难吗
Alice: Do you know how hard that is?
Lucia:知道有多难吗
Lucia: Do you know how hard it is?
Alice:我都快拼瞎了
Alice: I nearly went blind trying to do it.
Shure: 不是
Shure: No,
Shure: 你我
Shure: you and I...
Jake:哈哈哈一个币很难挣的
Jake: Hahaha, earning one coin is really tough.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 你这是破坏市场
Shure: You're disrupting the market.
Jake:你知道现在一个
Jake: Do you know that now one...
Tasha:你才是
Tasha:你知道现在一个矿业吗
Tasha: Do you know what mining is now?
Tasha:真的剥削你知道吗
Tasha: It's real exploitation, you know?
Jake:一个矿业多少钱吗
Jake: Do you know how much a mine costs?
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Lucia: 你说是big矿业吗
Lucia: Are you talking about big mining?
Tasha:什么
Tasha: What?
Lucia:他说一个矿多少钱
Lucia: He said how much a mine costs.
Lucia:我说是比特币吗
Lucia: I mean, like Bitcoin?
Lucia:哈哈哈这差不多吧
Lucia: Hahaha, it's almost the same, right?
Jake:一开始也不值钱对吧
Jake: At first, it wasn't worth anything, right?
Alice:我们都快拼瞎了
Alice: We nearly went blind trying.
Lucia:那你真得把咱这上链上链
Lucia: Then you really need to put it on the blockchain.
Lucia:给他注成NFT算了
Lucia: Just make it an NFT.
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yeah.
Alice:没关系要不然就按时间吧
Alice: It's okay, or we can just do it by time.
Shure: 阿猫阿猫通他们都在NFT
Shure: Everyone from Amao to NFT is on it.
Shure: 元宇宙 我元你家的激发宇宙
Shure: Metaverse, my metaverse inspires yours.
Alice:能坐上15分钟就给他个两三个之类的
Alice: If you can sit for 15 minutes, give him two or three or something.
Jake:什么呀什么东西
Jake: What? What's that?
Lucia:木子膏呀
Lucia: Muzigao.
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure: 你不知道这
Shure: You don't know this?
Lucia:有一首歌
Lucia: There's a song.
Shure: 是的热狗的一首歌叫做NFT
Shure: Yes, a song by Hotdog called NFT.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:听懂一个词
Jake: I understood one word.
Lucia: 感觉都是哔哔哔
Lucia: Feels like it's all beep beep beep.
Lucia:哈哈哈对自带消音效果
Lucia: Hahaha, yeah, it comes with its own censoring.
Shure: 可以听一下这个词
Shure: You should listen to that word.
Katrina: 那就这样
Katrina: So that's it.
Katrina: 3点哈哈哈
Katrina: 3 o'clock, hahaha
Jake:行行行
Jake: Okay, okay.
Katrina: 3点到3:40是他们自我介绍
Katrina: From 3 to 3:40 is their self-introduction.
Katrina: 和我们的知识问答
Katrina: And our Q&A session.
Katrina: 然后3:40到4:20是我们host part
Katrina: Then from 3:40 to 4:20 is our host part.
Katrina: 就是我们介绍我们每个人的东西
Katrina: That's where we introduce our stuff.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina: 4:20到5点是他们介绍他们带来的东西
Katrina: From 4:20 to 5 is where they introduce their items.
Katrina: 拍卖嗯
Katrina: Auction, yeah.
Katrina: 然后5点半左右就是订的
Katrina: And around 5:30 is the order.
Katrina: 然后就是披萨
Katrina: And then pizza.
Katrina: 然后6点
Katrina: Then at 6.
Katrina: 6点多的时候就可以开始唱
Katrina: Around 6 we can start singing.
Katrina: 唱歌什么的
Katrina: Singing and stuff.
Katrina: 晚上就指定了
Katrina: The evening is set.
Katrina: 唱歌好像
Katrina: Seems like singing.
Jake:对晚上没啥大吃
Jake: Yeah, there's no big meal in the evening.
Katrina: 哦哦我想起来就是那个呃
Katrina: Oh, oh, I remembered, it's um...
Katrina: 4:20 host part结束以后最后压轴的是他们
Katrina: After the host part ends at 4:20, the finale is theirs.
Katrina: 然后就可以尝一下他的甜品嗯
Katrina: And then we can try their desserts.
Jake:啊是我不是
Jake: Ah, was it me?
Jake:这本来就是吗
Jake: Wasn't it always like this?
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Jake:嗑完为
Jake: Finished talking.
Katrina: 早上做来得及吗
Katrina: Is there time to do it in the morning?
Shure: 哎不行
Shure: No, can't do.
Katrina: 3点才开始嘞
Katrina: It starts at 3.
Shure: 卫多美哈哈哈哈
Shure: Very funny, haha.
Lucia: 番茄沙司吗
Lucia: Ketchup?
Shure: 好利来没说
Shure: Hollyland didn't mention.
Shure: 卫多美可能不知道
Shure: Maybe Vedome doesn't know.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Katrina: 然后那个什么调节
Katrina: Then what about adjustments?
Shure: 卢锡河
Shure: Lucy River.
Katrina: 今天晚上就指定了一个这个活动
Katrina: Tonight there's only one event.
Katrina: 唱唱歌然后8点结束
Katrina: Singing until 8.
Katrina: 差不多6点开
Katrina: Starting around 6.
Katrina: 65点半的
Katrina: 6 or 6:30.
Katrina: 晚饭的话可能6:15开始吧
Katrina: Dinner might start at 6:15.
Katrina: 6:15-8点唱歌一个多小时
Katrina: 6:15 to 8, singing for over an hour.
Katrina: 嗯嗯没了
Katrina: Mm-hmm, that's it.
Shure: 差不多
Shure: Pretty much.
Shure: 行我们批一点
Shure: Alright, let's approve some.
Shure: 不要那么高
Shure: Don't make it too high.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Okay.
Jake:咱那个barbecue是啥意思
Jake: What's the meaning of that barbecue thing?
Katrina: barbeque还搞吗
Katrina: Are we still doing the barbecue?
Katrina: barbeque那碳昨天剩了半天咋
Katrina: We had some charcoal left over from yesterday, what about that?
Jake:现在啥意思
Jake: What now?
Jake:要不从明天开始烧吧
Jake: How about we start grilling from tomorrow?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 烧没了给
Shure: Use up all the charcoal.
Katrina: 这很难找
Katrina: This is hard to find.
Shure: 那个有点太困难了
Shure: That might be a bit too difficult.
Jake:哈哈哈东北人
Jake: Hahaha, Northerners.
Shure: 是不是
Shure: Right?
Shure: 是不是咱们昨天自个吃上了吧
Shure: Didn't we eat it ourselves yesterday?
Jake:是吃上了
Jake: We did.
Lucia:是
Lucia: Yes.
Jake:花了两个小时吃上了
Jake: It took us two hours to eat it.
Jake:那如果要搞barbecue的话
Jake: So if we're going to do the barbecue...
Katrina: 不是明天又得去采购吗
Katrina: Don't we have to go shopping again tomorrow?
Jake:是买点直接买点串好的之类的
Jake: Yeah, we should just buy some pre-skewered stuff.
Jake:就美团嘛是吧
Jake: Just order it on Meituan, right?
Lucia:要不别烤了
Lucia: Or maybe we shouldn't grill.
Shure: 要不直接点熟的
Shure: Or just order cooked food.
Jake:熟的直接烧
Jake: Cooked food and then grill it.
Jake:对熟的然后再在烤箱上面温
Jake: Yeah, cook it and then warm it up in the oven.
Shure: 温着温着
Shure: Warm it up, warm it up.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Lucia: 因为这个烧起来的时间
Lucia: Because the cooking time...
Lucia:可能是三到更无穷所以就太难控制了
Lucia: Might be from three to infinity, so it's too hard to control.
Katrina: 还有咱那个酒的那个饮料也没了
Katrina: And we're out of drinks for the alcohol.
Katrina: 我们那个酒的饮料啊
Katrina: Our drinks for the alcohol, you know.
Katrina: 维他
Katrina: Vita.
Shure: 酒yes维他
Shure: Alcohol, yes, Vita.
Katrina: 外卖吧
Katrina: Let's order takeout.
Shure: 然后哦
Shure: And then, oh.
Shure: 明天那个dinner time的时候喷个香槟
Shure: Tomorrow during dinner time, let's pop some champagne.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Jake:哦这回给力点哈给力点
Jake: Oh, this time, give it a little more effort, okay?
Shure: 这这回必须得优雅的
Shure: This time, it has to be elegant.
Shure: 这回我就手崩坏了
Shure: This time, my hand is going to mess up.
Shure: 我都得把这香槟崩出去
Shure: I might end up popping the champagne.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 哈哈哈要么就是我手飞出去
Shure: Hahaha, or my hand might fly off.
Shure: 要么就是盖飞出去
Shure: Or the cap might fly off.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 这吓人
Katrina: This is scary.
Jake:行
Jake: Alright.
Katrina: 没了
Katrina: That's it.
Jake:没了
Jake: That's it.
Shure: 没了
Shure: That's it.
Shure: 要不就这样
Shure: Or let's just do it like this.
Jake:就这样
Jake: Just like this.
Shure: 那休息
Shure: Then let's rest.
Alice:还有装饰房间的
Alice: There's still decorating the room.
Jake:装饰房间是
Jake: Decorating the room is...
Katrina: 装饰房间
Katrina: Decorating the room.
Katrina: 要给他们看吗
Katrina: Should we show them?
Katrina: 还是就我们自己内部看看
Katrina: Or just keep it for ourselves?
Jake:呃他给他们看
Jake: Uh, show them.
Jake:因为不是不是藏东西得
Jake: Because it's not something we should hide.
Tasha: 藏到房间里
Tasha: Hide it in the room.
Jake:合适吗
Jake: Is that appropriate?
Shure: 不合适吧
Shure: Probably not appropriate.
Jake:不合适
Jake: Not appropriate.
Shure: 哈哈哈你笑什么
Shure: Hahaha, why are you laughing?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 没笑
Katrina: I'm not laughing.
Shure: 你仿佛看到了什么一样
Shure: It's like you saw something.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Katrina: 没看见
Katrina: I didn't see anything.
Shure: 不是你脸为什么那么红
Shure: Then why is your face so red?
Shure: 你看到我什么了吗
Shure: Did you see something about me?
Katrina: 没有
Katrina: No.
Katrina: 哈哈哈我脸红了吗我没喝
Katrina: Hahaha, is my face red? I haven't even had a drink.
Jake:是
Jake: It is.
Shure: 确实
Shure: It really is.
Jake:确实
Jake: It really is.
Katrina: 那就那个环节设置在哪啊
Katrina: So where should we set that segment?
Jake:那个环节
Jake: That segment.
Jake:incho吧就在这
Jake: Incho, just right here.
Jake:可能Q a之前就是暖场吧
Jake: Maybe before Q&A, let's do a warm-up.
Katrina: 就是两点半到三点
Katrina: So from 2:30 to 3:00?
Jake:对两点半到三
Jake: Yes, 2:30 to 3:00.
Jake:三点一开始先暖个场吧
Jake: At 3:00, let's do a warm-up first.
Jake:大家转一圈
Jake: Everyone takes a lap.
Jake:然后坐坐到座位上
Jake: Then sit down at the seats.
Katrina: OK对那就
Katrina: OK, right.
Jake:就是三点
Jake: So at 3:00.
Katrina: 可以
Katrina: Got it.
Jake:大家游戏
Jake: Everyone plays games.
Jake:就是在客厅这边
Jake: In the living room area.
Jake:把币给把撒的币给找着
Jake: Find the scattered coins.
Jake:然后找完之后就开始开始
Jake: After finding them, we start.
Jake:然后大家每个人带他们走一圈
Jake: Then everyone takes them around for a lap.
Jake:走一圈之后买东西
Jake: After a lap, we buy things.
Shure: 好
Shure: Alright.
Katrina: 行
Katrina: Okay.
Jake:行
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 我们是不是
Shure: Should we...
Shure: 杨老板应该做个总体的presentation呢
Shure: Jake, shouldn't you give an overall presentation?
Jake:做做一个
Jake: Sure, I'll do one.
Jake:做个开场呗
Jake: I'll do an opening.
Jake:对欢迎各位嘉宾各位领导
Jake: Yes, welcome all the guests and leaders.
Shure: 杨老板得做一个小的小的答辩是吧
Shure: Jake should do a small defense, right?
Shure: 对我们为难为难他
Shure: Yes, let's make it difficult for him.
Shure: 为什么要这么做
Shure: Why do we need to do this?
Shure: 百度让我这么做的哈哈哈
Shure: Because Baidu told me to, haha.
Shure: 这就是我的答辩
Shure: That's my defense.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Shure: 我真的挺好答的
Shure: It's really quite easy to answer.
Lucia:只答不辩
Lucia: Just answer, no defense.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Jake:那就收工
Jake: Then let's wrap it up.
Jake:收工
Jake: Wrap it up.
Shure: 关卧好
Shure: Close the room, alright.
Shure: 交还
Shure: Returning.
Shure: 哎哟终于找到我手机了
Shure: Oh man, I finally found my phone.
Jake:T024
Jake: T024
Shure: T024
Shure: 马恩山要开音乐节啦
Shure: There's going to be a music festival at Maen Mountain!
Nicous: 你要去啊
Nicous: Are you going?
Shure: 这你随便可以搞到是吧
Shure: You can get it easily, right?
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Jake:马恩山之王
Jake: King of Maen Mountain.
Jake:山叫什么
Jake: What's the mountain called?
Jake:山大王
Jake: Mountain King.
Shure: 我草
Shure: Damn.
Jake:山大王是吗
Jake: Mountain King, right?
Shure: 马恩山山大王ok ok
Shure: Maen Mountain King, okay, okay.
Jake:跟你一个桌吃饭
Jake: Eating at the same table with you.
Jake:这个是
Jake: This is...
Jake:你先给它关了吗
Jake: Did you turn it off first?
Jake:哦靠没手了
Jake: Oh man, no hands left.
Jake:来帮我扔下去给它送下去
Jake: Come, help me throw it down, send it down.